l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono bravi jane prima di
cominciare ragazzi con il video di oggi
volevo ringraziarvi perché proprio ieri
ragazzi abbiamo raggiunto un traguardo
disumano a volte li vogliono sanno però
che lo ripeto lo stesso abbiamo
raggiunto ragazzi un miliardo di
visualizzazioni un miliardo un miliardo
si intende un miliardo di
visualizzazioni totali per i video che
fuori di testa un miliardo di grazie non
basterebbero quindi neanche senso però
tutto il supporto che ogni giorno mi
date mi dà veramente una soddisfazione
incredibile quante volte ho fatto così
sembra che sto prendendo la tastiera
hadash a tema o ragazzi parte questo
passiamo al video di oggi altro ieri
ragazzi abbiamo fatto serata con i
ragazzi social face
vi lascio un pezzo della serata giusto
per farvi capire rapper italiani che
youtubers italiani che è qui per
salvaguardare la dignità di qualsiasi
persona presente nel video mi fermo il
giorno dopo siamo andati da sky per
vedere la puntata di social face regali
si sperimenta c'è la televisione o addio
sono noi che bello
cos'è cos'è a no sta indicando che rifai
oddio in cev a caso il frigobar
i ragazzi che siamo in un ufficio
interesse della nostra serie a questa
situazione
[Musica]
no no no non è steso peraltro fi
vai faccia sempre molto belli faccia
simone che schifo
raga un'idea
[Musica]
[Applauso]
de luca è scattata per partire a social
day vi attaccate a questo programma
contiene cose brutte stronzi quelli che
lo fanno e dopo aver visto la puntata
dopo aver cenato sono andato a casa dei
mail e qui è partita lino razza quella
seria ok ragazzi abbiamo finito una
serata tipo che abbiamo mangiato insieme
siamo andati da sky mi sono [ __ ]
questo che sarebbe tipo l'icona di sky
atlantic per portarmelo a casa a
prendermela sulla porta e ho fatto un
salto alla casa dei dei mei e ho
guardato un po dove armitano cristo e
della colla spray
questa è la camera di sori al papa io vi
giuro che volevo soltanto testarlo lo
spray non avrei mai pensato che ne
sarebbe uscito così tanto e ho fatto
ovviamente un casino
niente niente niente niente niente
niente
ma non è vero non ho sfruttato niente
c'è un'uscita dal balcone non voglio
niente discusso questo a posto
cosa episodio di una cifra minore era
capito ciò le cose in questo nome
no non è vero dai apriste non posso
stare con o comunque straordinaria no no
ho tentato disperatamente di pulire la
colla mentre gli altri erano fuori senza
che nessuno mi vedesse ma ormai si era
bella e asciugata è invece sul rimini
chiamato di brutto
[Risate]
ho sbagliato non pensieri non pensavo
che uscisse così tanta dello zio tom
cos'è io ti giuro che non volevo
spruzzarla li volevo provare in coso
vedere quanto spruzzavano costeggia in
ci tagliamo la testa parli ragazzi la
cucina io vi prego iddio
la cosa che si sistemano se non facciamo
vedere no ma tu non hai visto a casa mia
questa non è ok perfetto attenzione
hanno queste non si fanno vedere in
questo mondo
ebbene non c'avevo bisogna avere meno
andata così e poi attenzione signore e
signori le chiavi e la pasta al sugo
mi spiegate per quale motivo
in casa sì ho capito ma perché perché
anche ristorante la passione si torna ai
piatti questo cose vivo attenzione che
queste primi prende il design del
appendi abile a casa sesto il camice del
milan per cucinare esatto nudi però sono
andati sotto noi dice sapete star eletto
si già è vero ma latina formazioni fai
ti giuro è venuto benissimo è insomma la
grava farlo perché lo faccio negli hotel
no perché con il fatto che inarca la
schiena più della di più e genialate sa
bene che accresce ordine questa cosa mi
piace cioè nel senso rispetto a casa mia
c'è ordine un sacco con mister perché
non hai vinto a causare la persona
diventare vichinghi cos'è quella roba
perché perché sì ma perché perché
arrivato punto si fa perché lì non so
dove mettere è un capriccio le botti gli
ignoranti ma perché l'high line effetti
speciali ragazzo ci sono gli effetti
speciali per aprirne l'albero di natale
ma sai che le bottiglie così che si
illuminano un cielo manco io che sono le
tamarrate in sala porca [ __ ] com'è
possibile
mi fiacca guarda che ne abbiamo parecchi
bilanci video così ci stava e l'africa è
sotto 20 20 tipologie cilag gigi da che
adesso le bottiglie ricchezze che la sua
cassaforte sia insicuro carica misura in
un gran massa forte però non da muro 3 1
rosati è vero ma sono fantastiche alla
casa propria per quello cosa per
metterci dentro un posto dell'interno ho
capito ma non parlando stampa compra un
cassetto che mi trovo di persone questa
cosa mi sono girato non lo so proprio
così è stata una cagà spiegami
questo perché cagare in piazza duomo ore
se rimini nord in una cucina che cos'è
sta roba è una vastissima diffusa una
bellissima canonica bello e quindi
ragazzi questo è stata la giornata
ignorante di ieri praticamente sono in
debito di un berretto con paciello è di
un muro con suri è quindi ragazzi spero
che video vi sia piaciuto che io vi
ringrazio ancora per il traguardo
raggiunto proprio ieri come al solito sv
dove piaciuto lasciato un commento è un
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
come l'editor tenere stinziani saresti
d'ischia tricicli diavolo proseguito
bella ragazza